[Musique]
martin biron michel david christian
dufour bonsoir affaires camara je vous
fais entendre le ministre genève
barrette qui dit oui on doit connaître
la vérité dans cette histoire leur dois
aller creuser dans la requête qui a été
fait est ce qu'on à tourner les coins
ronds ou non on écoute les québécois et
ont été choqués ce qui permet à monsieur
camara
c'est un événement qui est très
particulier très traumatisant pour lui
aussi alors je pense que une enquête
indépendante pour faire la lumière sur
ces évènements du québec est
présentement au travail à ce niveau là
et il y aura des développements pour les
prochains jours il y aura des
développements cours des prochains jours
la mairesse viennent nous dire donnez
nous quelques jours jean contact avec
québec
on croit comprendre martin ça va être un
observateur qu'on va envoyer ce sera pas
le berry ou un organisme doit être une
personne qui va aller mettre son nez
dans la requête
on devrait savoir tout ça cette semaine
on est en train d'attacher les fils
effectivement ce sera paul le bureau des
enquêtes indépendantes
essentiellement c'est une organisation
qui en a plein les bras il ya beaucoup
de dossiers qui vola mais en plus c'est
pas tout à fait son mandat le mandat du
du bo é
c'est d'enquêté quand tu as utilisation
d'une arme d'un policier quand il ya un
blessé ou un mort il y en a eu un
mais on parle pas de salon on
s'intéresse aux pratiques des enquêtes
policières est ce que on a tous fait là
et comment on a fait les choses pour
arrêter monsieur camara alors
possiblement peut-être un ancien juge
peut être un ancien policier ou enfin
quelqu'un qui connaît bien le travail
des policiers
cette personne l'or a touché un peu à
comment être été différent
qui est à la retraite là qui attend de
savoir c'est vrai quand j'ai dit
l'ancien grand patron laisse qu'une en
sus le nom il soumis mais je vais
écouter ça ne change pas c'est qui cette
semaine 6 à sa tâche bien parce que
quand même il n'y a pas beaucoup de gens
qui sont capables de faire ça et de bien
le faire et il faut les convaincre
parce que c'est pas toujours facile
d'enquêter auprès de la police mais
juste pour conclure la mairesse parlait
de légers efficace moi j'ai entendu
aujourd'hui rapide et public c'est à
dire qu'on veut pas une enquête va
s'éterniser et on veut qu'ils conclusion
soit mais au point où on en est michel
et christian ça prend quelque chose là
je pense est clair michel
oui c'est évident ce sera quelque chose
après quelque chose assez rapide
d'effectivement s portal 2
comment dire d'examiner le
fonctionnement du corps de police deux
aides
il faut il faut arriver à une conclusion
rapide mais il ya beaucoup de questions
qui se posent quand même là comment ça
se fait qu'on a pu accuser quelqu'un
aussi rapidement et de toute évidence
sur des bases extrêmement fragile
inévitablement la question du profilage
racial vont être posées
je suis pas convaincu que ces l'icop
peut-être peut-être que non là on a une
victime qui est le policier qui est
d'origine indienne le
celui qui était accusé mais qu'il est
qui qui qui était pas responsable des
africaines reçu le
le suspect en cavale serait lui aussi
alors est-ce que je ne sais pas mais il
est clair que le
la personne qui va faire la requête ne
pourra pas éviter de se poser la
question
ouais qui sait oui bah si c'est clair
qu'il faut une enquête
rappelons qu ont eu quand même une très
bonne nouvelle aujourd'hui dans un
docile qu'on attendait vrai parce qu'ils
détectent pourri parce que les chefs de
police de montréal s'est déplacé pour
s'excuser auprès de monsieur camara et
monsieur camara excuses et accepté ses
excuses vous interrompre son avocate
zaoui accepté mais ça veut pas dire
accepter accepté puis on tourne la page
donc on ne sait pas ce que j'ai dit
patrice poingt s'est simplement dit que
l'intrus mais accepter les excuses et
dans ces dossiers le monde a
l'impression que on n'est que dans la
rancune doivent être dans la
vérification qui ça vient toujours pire
c'est clair qu'il faut une enquête
surtout que au fond dans ce dossier les
deux victimes des yeux tout d'abord le
policier qui a été sauvagement agressé
il faut pas oublier aussi monsieur
camara et dans les deux cas ils se
rattachent à des groupes à l'identité
forte si vous permettez l'expression qui
ira quand même l'objectivité difficile
on sait quand un policier est agressé
une espèce de réactions de solidarité
des autres policiers très émotif qui
rend difficile pour les policiers d'être
objectif et que la même façon quand ces
questions de racisme au lieu des groupes
dans la société
au fond qui défendra ses systèmes et
profilage racial donc ce qui dans donkey
son bien et soul et donc à ce moment là
je trouve très important qu'on ait une
enquête indépendante comme mes collègues
l'ont dit rapide frange topo que ça
pourrisse plus de moi je tenais quand
même à le souligner le chef de police va
être humain monsieur caron s'est déplacé
pour aller s'excuser auprès de monsieur
camara et monsieur camara a accepté ses
excuses c'est très important
oui martine la mer s à qui j'ai posé la
question jeudi
la mairesse on en a parlé ensemble
s'était étiré le cou l'avait dit cet
homme là est innocent il faut le crier
haut et fort il a été et c'est une
erreur judiciaire etc
elle devait mieux respirer vendredi
quand le chef de police lui même est
ressorti à 10 ha bon mais je viens de
recevoir ce matin les
les échantillons d adn effectivement on
discute mais ça c'est arrivé le
lendemain je veux entendre la mairesse
qui reconnaît qu qu'elle est allée un
peu loin dans son dans sa lancée jeudi
après-midi
écoutez je me cacherais pas que ce soit
le jeudi
idéalement j'aurais pu rajouter avec les
informations que nous avons il est
innocent comprenez jamais pu ramener
sain et c'est vrai que je lis pas fait
donc je suis heureux de savoir que un
petit monde qui pour moi c'est tel quel
mais moi je suis surtout heureuse de
savoir que pour cet homme là le calvaire
il se fasse autre chose mais au moins ce
boulot c'est plus sur ses épaules
vraiment on le disait vendredi qu'on eut
le coup de théâtre
martin qu'elle devait mieux respirer
suite au petit point de presse la
déclaration monsieur caron la mairesse
oui mais effectivement elle certainement
mieux respirant fait semaine parce
qu'elle n'était pas dans l'erreur mais
quand même on sentait dans l'entrevue
qu'elle faisait de nickel tirer leçon
est que
le seuil est de faire une certaine
gestion de la situation parce que c'est
vrai que son rôle c'est d'être en phase
avec ce qui se passe dans la population
mais c'est aussi son rôle d'avoir de
s'élever dans sa fonction d'expliquer
aux citoyens ce qui se passe et c'est
aussi la patronne du service dur pour
des policiers de montréal alors et doit
aussi faire en fait le lien entre tout
ça je sais que c'est pas facile pour
elle mais c'est un puceau job et c'est
un peu ce qu'elle faisait aujourd'hui
elle essayait de dire bt oui je comprend
ce qui se passe avec les policiers oui
je suis proche des citoyens peuvent en
effet on peut pas exclure non plus le
fait qu'elle est en année électorale
oui c'est ça qui est maintenant qu'on
lui dit vous n'avez pas si réagi
christian mais il reste que moi j'ai pas
toujours hyper fan de madame mélodies
impressionne un peu d'adn est comme ça
qu'elle est allée un peu trop loin je
prends je pense qu'elle marquait un peu
à son obligation de réserve et que
maintenant elle est soulagée est capable
de la tête
chapeau parce que c'est un dossier moi
je trouve je le répète qui peut devenir
très très pourri et tout le monde a
intérêt à être très responsable très
humain et très lucide et très très
prudent madame
adam plantes dit oui mais la présomption
d'innocence est important c'est très
important mais c'est pas ça qu'elle a
dit jeudi à l'ats dit il est innocent à
la peau dit il faut tenir compte de la
présomption d'innocence alors c'est
évident que le corps de police a pris ça
comme une forme de désaveu safer dira
écoutez vous êtes trop vite alors je
comprends qu'ils sortent au comptant qui
sait les issues francoeur évidemment
défendre leurs membres puis monsieur
francoeur pas la langue dans sa poche
mais ça ça crée un climat il était
sidérant avertit l'ecri vous entendant
plein point de presse présumer des
conclusions d'une enquête de police
complexe délicate et surtout active
dans évita blement il va en rester
quelque chose oui pourquoi dire ça
beaucoup moi je vous avoue que je n'aime
pas qu'on dise ça pour quoi dire il va
rester quelques jours c'est pas terminé
parce que parce que c'est super mais cet
homme c'est un dossier qui est un
processus que je devais chercher à ce
que paul ici pourquoi dis que ça alors
c'est pas du jeu parce que les policiers
puissent est une celle enquêteur où la
houle enquête 13 devra déterminer à la
question de fond
martin pendant parle depuis jeudi
dernier c est ce que un policier de
bonne foi aurait commettrait encore la
même erreur autrement dit quand le
policier attaques et dit c'est le
dernier à qui j'ai donné une
contravention qui m'a fait soeur quand
la silhouette peut sembler comme celle
de camara car on peut de bonne foi ne
pas voir la troisième personne
l'ombre en fait sur le vidéo de gendt et
q c'est ça qu'on veut savoir parce que
peut-être qu'il était vraiment au
mauvais endroit au mauvais moment
monsieur camara et qu'un autre faut
quand même y penser qu'un autre vienne
par en arrière attaqué le policier c'est
dur à comprendre martin au départ c'est
ben c'est ça que le l'enquêteur le qui
sera nommé indépendant devra déterminer
c'est si les pratiques qu'on était bien
suivi les meilleures pratiques en
matière d' enquête policière est ce que
par exemple il aurait dû faire appel à
un tiers extérieur pour être un peu pour
que cette personne ne soit plus dégagée
est ce que on sera arriver au même
résultat
c'est ce genre de questions que devra se
poser l'enquêteur est commencé et est
traité à partir du moment où on a décidé
qu'il y avait suffisamment de preuves
pour mettre monsieur camara en
accusation et comment se fait-il que sa
prise six jours comment se fait-il que
monsieur camara était
emprisonné pendant six jours alors c'est
tous ces détails là qui viennent
ensemble puis oui et c'est vrai que
monsieur camara c'est pouvant pas ce
qu'il a vécu
mais les policiers quand y'a un des
leurs qui se fait attaquer aussi
violemment de cette façon là ça reste
quand même un enjeu important et c'est
normal que les policiers réagissent
fortement bon très bien je veux vous
parler de l'autre l'autre seuil qu'on a
atteint en fin de semaine on le savait
le dus au québec le 10 mille morts je
vous montre un tableau le décès par 100
1000 habitants alors québec champion
toute catégorie au canada la moyenne
canadienne est de 54 mais ça c'est avec
la moyenne du québec
donc ce sera même plus basses ont enlevé
lé québec sont faisait le reste du
canada l'ontario 44 la france qui est au
dessus du québec 121 des états unis et
la belgique etats unis belgique sont les
deux pires pays alors on en a beaucoup
parlé des sièges à celle d'hier on a
beaucoup parlé du type de placement
qu'on avait de la densité de personnes
âgées au québec
je pars de l'autre côté christian dufour
tour de table il faudra qu'on se
souvienne de ces chiffres-là longtemps
quand même oui pourtant c'est un
déshonneur nationale c'est sûr je dis
tout le temps il ya quand même quelque
chose qui est mystérieux là dedans parce
que ça prend attache et la crédibilité
du gouvernement
legault même si le bilan est
objectivement désastreux on peut dire
que monsieur lavaud était très
rassembleur très habile mais je pense
aussi que ça choix de les québécois les
quelque chose qu'ils veulent pas voir
qu'ils veulent pas à m admettre
collectivement donc il ya deux éléments
montrent que le 10 mai de marle ce qui
est arrivé c'est terrible mais ce qui
est encore plus terrible de patrice à
mon sens c'est que je sois sûr que ça va
nous amener à changer réellement des
choses dans le système de santé
des fois il ya nous amènent à changer
des comportements collectifs dans ce que
l'on peut vraiment se poser la question
jusqu'à quel point ça va nous amener à
remettre en cause fondamentalement la
façon dont on fonctionne dans ce domaine
le monstre ou ferait vraiment avoir une
grosse commission d'arc est réelle le
prêt juste pour dépasser 2
argent puis prendre du temps puis avec
avoir de la paperasse mais ça nous met
en face de nous mêmes les québécois on a
beaucoup de difficulté est en face de
nous mêmes parce que globalement la
population québec semble relativement
satisfait de la façon dont a été gérée
il ya quelque chose d'aberrant la jetro
michel david ouais moi je pense qu'il va
y avoir quelque chose qui va se passer
ce que ça va être suffisant je ne sais
pas il va y avoir une enquête publique
je pense que d'une manière ou d'une
autre on pourra pas l'éviter et il va y
avoir des changements qui devront
s'opérer bon on le sait déjà il va avoir
des maisons des aînés qui vont être dans
le fond dessert chasse ltée plus moderne
plus fonctionnel mais on pourra
probablement pas le transformer tous les
ch à celle d un immeuble ultramoderne
efficace alors il faudrait travailler
d'une part vers la rénovation des ch a
cédé mais aussi de ne pas beaucoup sur
les soins à domicile pour éviter qu'il y
ait des gens qui sont à la maison et
dont la santé se dégrade
parce que ils ont pas de soins et qui
aboutissent dans cette baie on voit
toujours en avoir besoin il ya des gens
qui vont avoir besoin ultime en d'être
dans un centre de longue durée mais je
pense qu'il faut travailler vraiment les
deux morceaux la volonté je pense
monsieur legault leur réellement la
question c'est toujours la même
quand on va voir passer la pandémie il
va avoir douze mille priorité la relance
économique l'environnement tout ce que
vous voudrez et à ce moment alors est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'on va sacrifier disons
en terme de budget pour envoyer du côté
des des soins aux personnes âgées
alors est-ce qu'on va construire moins
de route - d'école - ce convoi et
augmenter des impôts
il ya beaucoup de questions qui vont
d'avoir discuté à la veille d'une
élection dont augmenter les impôts c'est
rarement la solution que le gouvernement
choisit martin 12 2 secondes
mais michel c'est pas juste une question
d'argent c'est trop facile de dire c'est
pas une question d'argent avant tout
c'est toute notre mode de fonctionnement
collectif québécois qui sont remis en
cause et moi je trouve c'est très dur
pour nous de confronter ça c'est pas
juste une question d'argent mais ce que
je veux c'est par les battre parce qu'il
ya un taux de placement plus élevé au
québec dans les sachets celle des
carrières le québec vieillit avec le
japon et la société des sociétés les
plus vieilles sur la planète martin
biron docteur réjean hébert nous a parlé
à deux semaines dans le reçoit ce soir à
l'émission télé journal aussi lui dit
que c'est urgent il faut qu'on prenne
les bouchées doubles michel en parlait
soins domicile parce que ça s'est un peu
de l'argent aussi soins à domicile mais
aussi toute une
il faut réfléchir à la place des
personnes âgées dans notre société ce
qui va être très difficile je pense pour
le gouvernement
dans la dernière année de son mandat
c'est que les gens vont vouloir avoir
des changements rapides les maisons des
aînés c'est vrai que ça fait rêver
c'est magnifique mais les gens vont
vouloir avoir des changements tout de
suite et à peu près tout le monde se
rend compte que le système de santé la
ccl des brindilles qui le tiennent et
que c'est difficile pour les personnes
âgées mais c'est difficile aussi pour le
système en général le délestage on en a
amplement parlé
alors comment le gouvernement va placer
ses priorités parce que il va avoir des
choix déchirants à faire et là c'est les
différentes pressions populaires que
vont faire où il va et qui vont faire
que vous redis ce qui va décider où il
va mais ils vont être confrontés à
beaucoup de pression mais c'est un
bulletin dont il faut se rappeler la
toile un bulletin dont il faut se
rappeler
collectivement on est on est mort deux
fois mon cher quelque chose d'aussi ont
cadencé faut l'oublier faut pas
l'oublier parce qu'on le trouve bien
jusqu'à présent pour faire semblant que
ça existe au porche très bien merci
beaucoup à vous trois à très bientôt
bonne soirée au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit